foreign
picture this
you're in your car and you're getting
worried
you were really really relying on that
fuel station being open
now you're not sure you're going to make
it to the next one you see on your map
and this area is notorious for
unreliable stations
you definitely don't have enough range
to make it to the one that you know is
usually working or even the one that at
least has decent customer service on
their helpline when it's down
so you slow way down to conserve energy
and sigh when you see a giant Hill
coming up on the freeway ahead of you
the way people are driving there is no
way you're going to make it up this hill
at a safe highway speed without killing
your Energy Efficiency
it's hot out but you turn off your AC
and remind yourself again that charging
your phone in the car Outlet doesn't
actually use that much energy
man you think to yourself
I remember when this was a problem for
EVS
but when I bought this car I just didn't
think finding gasoline was ever going to
be this much of a problem
if we succeed at reaching International
climate goals the fossil fuel
infrastructure systems that support
about 80 percent of global energy
consumption will mostly if not entirely
retire over the next few decades
the global dominance of fossil fuels and
the global emergency of climate change
means that this retirement imperative
exists everywhere whether infrastructure
is relatively old like in the U.S where
I work on these issues and where most of
my examples come from or relatively
newer as in many countries with more
recent industrialization
what I'm talking about is Big
infrastructure like power plants and
refineries but it's also things like gas
stations and people's cars stoves and
furnaces
fossil fuel infrastructure is a complex
network of high Hazard industries that
need to be able to continue to operate
safely until the new system is
completely ready to take over including
during emergencies Complicated by
climate change
just letting these systems go away would
be deeply disruptive and hazardous
we'd expect disproportionate harm to
overburdened and underserved communities
who can't opt out from skyrocketing
prices abandoned remediation plans and
declining access to Energy Services this
means ongoing fossil expenditures and a
Reliance on highly trained workers in
industries that might not Outlast their
careers with a simultaneous focus on
phasing out these same Industries as
quickly as possible to address climate
change and a host of other Environmental
injustices
this is why we need to plan
and right now there's basically nowhere
in the world where these urgently needed
plans for phasing out the fossil system
while phasing in the Clean Energy System
exist
when we talk about climate goals the
question I like to ask is if we actually
believed we were going to succeed what
would we need to be doing right now
the time between now and success is
where this gets real and very difficult
Sarah histing Simon and I call this the
mid-transition and even under a best
case scenario it will probably last for
decades
during the mid-transition the Clean
Energy System and the fossil Energy
System are both too small to fulfill all
of the energy needs we have but big
enough that they can't really operate
without constraining each other
also the mid-transition overlaps with
the climate transition this means we'd
expect the systems we have now to become
less functional as they operate further
and further outside of design parameters
and it also means we don't entirely know
what the new systems will need to be
able to handle
another issue here is that we'd also
expect that the transitioning system
will just generally work less well than
either the stable starting point or the
stable end point as long as both systems
are operating at scale we can't optimize
for either one's needs
people are often willing to accept some
level of problem in order to enable a
shared Future Vision but trust in that
Vision will be extraordinarily fragile
when it's required for decades while
climate impacts are making everything
scarier and while we're visibly
dismantling infrastructure that people
remember is functional
as we plan
keeping a clear and focused commitment
on people first and foremost and
ensuring that these are community-led
projects will be critical
one of the nice things about existing
energy infrastructure is it exists so
you can go to a power plant break room
and chat up people about how long they
expect to keep working or which bits of
the plant site might need remediation
this means planning can be very very
specific and guided by the expertise of
people that are in these places
who needs a job if the power plant
closes does everyone in town have safe
temperatures in their homes which gas
stations need to stay open longer than
they're profitable to make sure that
everybody can get to work while
alternative transportation systems
mature
how much extra funding do you need for
the library if tax revenues start to
decline
although good transition plans need to
be deeply Community embedded the scale
and the impact of the Energy System
demands some level of centralized
coordination
one strategy here is to set deadlines
for fossil asset retirements
ample notice say a decade gives
communities enough time to create and
Implement plans and a legislated end
date gives people enough confidence to
commit to what can be an intense process
I showed that in the United States
requiring all fossil fuel-fired power
generators to close by 2035 which is
President Biden's power sector
decarbonization Target would actually
allow the large majority of them to meet
or exceed a typical lifespan potentially
giving communities some confidence that
these deadlines are manageable that may
not be true in places with much newer
infrastructure and so the conversation
about how to choose these deadlines
would look quite different
but in general being honest with people
about what's coming with enough time and
support to do something about it can be
really transformative but it does
require a commitment to the end point
and to proactively ensuring people have
what they need to thrive alongside
transition
that is what earns and maintains trust
not far-off emissions targets with vague
implementation plans
the alternative of unplanned transitions
is unacceptable but common
notably this is what we would expect to
see if we just rely on clean energy
becoming cheap enough to displace fossil
Energy Systems
what I've observed over the years is
that facilities might close suddenly
with a round of layoffs and a bankruptcy
notification with very little notice and
no plan for what comes next
several years ago I was working on a
survey in a coal mining community and
the morning my survey hit people's
mailboxes about 500 coal miners were
suddenly laid off
just four U.S coal mining companies use
bankruptcy to avoid about five billion
dollars in pensions and environmental
cleanup obligations just between 2012
and 2017. the coal industry in the
United States is actually pretty small
now providing about 11 percent of
primary energy down from 18 a decade ago
we're talking about successfully
retiring and replacing infrastructure
that supports 80 percent of energy use
globally and in the United States all
before I reach retirement age
planning the transition is an ethical
responsibility that takes time but also
creates opportunities to implement
adjust and sustainable future that
corrects the harms of the past
collaboration and a laser-like focus on
ensuring people have what we need to
succeed through this transition will be
critical particularly as the transition
collides with climate tragedies
what would we do now if we believed we'd
succeed
anticipating the bumps and planning for
success is the path to adjust
decarbonized and sustainable world thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]